he's doing really well he is getting
better every single day
he's feeling
a lot better and obviously was just a
very
scary and random situation to happen
haley bieber promises fans justin is
recovering after announcing his ramsey
hunt diagnosis that left half his face
paralyzed this is pretty serious as you
can see
um
i wish this wasn't the case
but obviously my body's telling me i
gotta slow down
thanks for being patient with me
and uh i'm gonna get better
and i'm doing all these facial exercises
to get my face back to normal
haley stopped by good morning america
wednesday and shared the latest on her
husband's road to recovery the model
says justin is leaning on her for
support and it's only making their
marriage stronger i think the silver
lining of it honestly is that it brings
us a lot closer because you're going
through this together you're being there
for each other you're supporting each
other and there's just
something that really like bonds you
through through these times going
through it very publicly in front of a
lot of people
it kind of almost in a way forces you to
have to just be upfront about what's
going on so that people understand
what you're going through
earlier this week justin shared an
update with fans and revealed he's
relying on his faith to pull him through
writing on instagram this perspective
has given me peace during this horrific
storm that i'm facing i know this storm
will pass but in the meantime jesus is
with me it's gonna be okay and i have
hope and um i trust god and um i trust
that this is all gonna
it's all for a reason
2022 has been an especially challenging
year for the beavers back in march haley
suffered a health struggle of her own a
mini stroke and underwent open heart
surgery i felt this really weird
sensation that kind of like traveled
down my arm from my shoulder all the way
down to my fingertips justin was like
are you okay and
i just
didn't respond because i wasn't sure
right away he asked for somebody to
please call 9-1-1 and get a doctor
definitely the scariest moment of my
life at the time justin stood by her
side and now haley is revealing how
she's doing i feel a lot better after
that situation i feel good i you know i
had a procedure done to
close this hole in my heart and i'm just
giving my body the time to
heal and recover
it was it was a little hard for me to
recover from the procedure just giving
myself the time to be able to like work
out again and feel like normal if that
makes sense but i'm doing well now and
you know i'm not having to be on any
medication anymore with haley and justin
both on the men we're sending the
biebers lots of love and wishes for a
speedy recovery the support has been
really amazing just from fans friends
family like
every single person has sent well wishes
advice recommendations it's actually
been really amazing
[Music]
you